[Music]
what is going on there reject nation
greg here today before yes john is out
of commission at the moment yeah he's
recovering from surgery wish him well in
the comments currently working off of a
little bit of an all-nighter 9 20 in the
morning at the moment then this moon
night spot dropped and i was like ah
it's just 30 seconds long maybe there's
something new in it and then sure enough
when you think that you get a whole
bunch of dms of people going actually
greg there's a whole lot of new footage
in here it's like they all read in my
mind which is one of my split
personalities anyway yeah if you guys
can leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated i'm gonna keep this one
short today but it's moon night man keep
a lookout for our reactions we'll be
covering them on the channel as usual
[Music]
stephen
do you weren't supposed to see any of
this oh cool you sure you want to know
[Applause]
[Music]
damn that costume cannot tell the
difference
between life and dreams
am i like some sort of secret agent
it's a little more complicated than that
marvel studios
only on disney plus oh man i gotta watch
that again that just woke me up we can't
watch that again stephen
you weren't supposed to see any of this
what are you you sure you want to know
who am i you sure you want to know
i cannot get over how great that costume
looks
between my waking life and dreams
am i like some sort of secret agent
it's a little more complicated than that
marvel studios moon night only on disney
plus
i wonder if oscar isaac got multiple
paychecks because i know that sometimes
happens with people with actors if they
have to play like they play twins for
example you'll get paychecks for playing
two separate characters and i'm
wondering if in this case it did because
here he's you know he's playing steven
and he's playing mark spector so
probably not though it's probably not
the same thing so they all derive from
the same guy i mean my favorite parts
about it's like as cool as the costume
looks so much as i eat that [ __ ] up but
my favorite part of it is of course
scene that's why it's called secret
agent that makes a lot of sense it's
mark spector being a cia agent it's all
starting to click in the nugget here
anyway yeah when you look at this with
the ways handling conversations by
themselves there's always a variety of
ways you can handle that you can just
have like do some split screen with two
of them in the same room or it can look
like awkward cgi green screen stuff
going on considering the fact that you
look at the other trailers and they
already have so much ominous imagery
with mirrors and reflections and whatnot
have him interact with himself in sort
of this obscure reflection i think is
actually a great way to handle that it
seems like for sure that the main
character here will be
stephen grant at least at the kickoff
point that makes me curious how the
season itself will end like will this
season end now the dominant personality
you'll be hanging out with the audience
will be with is going to be mark spector
or will it still continue to be steven
knight because i like the approach of
steven knight is completely unaware of
the other personalities that personality
is where you're going to be the audience
decipher to experience this unraveling
of not only the physical mystery
surrounding him but also the internal
mysteries as well i think that's really
clever and part of the excitement with
the announcement of moon knight is oscar
isaac doing multiple personalities
getting to really showcase some of that
acting range watch him interact with
himself and then so seeing that here in
this clip was like my favorite element
of it while you get all the [ __ ] and
moon night stuff as well because even in
that dialogue exchange you sort of get
this sense that mark is trying to
protect steven which is cool to me
because you're gonna actually see a
relationship form with them versus like
hey look at the oscar isaac show of
acting talent you're gonna see a
relationship of interaction with each
other yeah the way to capture moonlight
man he's just there's something that's
so uh
godlike about the way he looks oh it's
beautiful beautiful anyway
thank you guys so much for being here um
i will catch you guys soon keep looking
for our moon now reactions
you